what we'll do is we'll get some random
words from different areas of the room
then we'll drop a beat and i'll do a
wrap if you are in this area of the room
would you like a rapper
samurai what was it about samurai that
interests you
gymnast team doctor
okay samurai swords yeah that's a good
word association samurai
if you are in this segment what would
you like a rap about
the viking that discovered the us the
viking that discovered the us oh yeah i
don't know if you guys know about this
but there was evidence that the vikings
had settlements in in america before
columbus came i mean obviously none of
them discovered it because you know
indigenous people but yeah
um
let's not you know let historical facts
get in the way of a good comedy wrap for
the vikings
people in the middle of the room so far
we have samurai swords and the vikings
who discovered america what would you
like to rap about
oh okay
someone here was about to say something
and i wish you'd said it sooner
you were gonna say paul rudd
so
[Music]
gay incest apparently
um great let's uh let's come to this
final corner of the room because that's
definitely your suggestions gay incest
everyone's so upset about that
that's your fault what would you like to
rap about over here
princess died oh yeah i mean i guess
she's having a kind of moment at the
moment in it everyone there's the movie
is it christian stuart in that movie is
paul rudd in it as well
um okay princess die gay incest
paul rudd samurai swords and the viking
who discovered america all right well
this is going to be fun this is how
we're ending the show we're doing a
freestyle rap about all those things um
it's not written it's not prepared it's
not rehearsed it's made up in the moment
and don't worry it will not be anywhere
near um as atrociously well because
playing as embarrassingly tokenly bad as
you're expecting it to be maybe turn up
a little bit more as well as we can why
is it sounding weird it's been a while
before they've been here right let's
close that and try that again
just imagine how good this rap would be
if we did a sound check
um okay we'll try one more time and if
not i'll just [ __ ] put it through the
microphone it'll sound
less good but um it's going to be about
gay incest so it'll be [ __ ] anyway
[Laughter]
oh we got it we fixed it nice
great so paul rudd gay incest the viking
who discovered america princess die and
samurai swords is what you ask for it's
what you're gonna get i think we'll
start with you are you excited for this
yeah because it's your words your little
phrase this you're a little personal
about some japanese dudes
[Music]
[Music]
and the right with the swipe i call it a
katana i hope you don't mind if it's got
a different name that i'm not aware of
put it back there then i'm taking off i
wanna pop people down only the guys if a
lady comes or catch me by surprise i
won't
by the paparazzi they were like oh
apologies princess d i a n and a wish
that they had gone the other way but
what should he do in her lifetime
divorce princess charles play the
landmine she would walk around with a
metal detector and everyone in war-torn
countries were like we respect you i
hope you don't die in an automobile
chase sadly she did but imagine the
other place where she's still existing
inject maybe she would cure the world of
all incest it doesn't really matter
either way if the incest is straight or
the incest is gay or is the incentive
princess died doesn't even care whether
it's a girl and a guy or a guy and a guy
or a girl and a guy and it up with
another girl right inside they'd be
having so much sex they'd be coming with
the blisters who are these people she's
my sister yeah i'll take a hunger and
they're all vista i'm also a woman yes i
can't resist a nice little rap about
this blood i've never seen much his
movies but paul rudd he's amenable ever
so likable you can watch his script that
he writes quite recyclable why because
they put him in a franchise already made
ghostbusters if you saw it you'd be
dismayed i know the fans liked it they
gave it a whirl i preferred the one that
they remade with all the girls but they
weren't related and having any sex you
can get a little moving and putting one
neck is the pain in the neck i don't
know all of his franchises lasting all
the vikings arriving coming overseas
they're like what is it they come in the
atlantic not the pacific on the east
coast landed maybe north of the border
maybe up in canada columbus was a
hoarder in the 1400s trying to steal all
the [ __ ] but the vikings they were there
on their big dragon ships coming over
see a little indian village i said i was
gonna rape and village and the indians
ran away scared of the swords the
vikings came in the helmet didn't have
horns but they weren't actually the
first to arrive who got there first some
[ __ ] samurai yeah
[Applause]